There is a new section
all assault allegation against Donald Trump.
Uh, in addition to the, what is it, 12 or
16 that already exist and this is a really
bad one.
This is an allegation of rape.
Now, I think because of the creeping normalization
that we've experienced in the United States
under Donald Trump for the last couple of
years, it's crazy.
I have to mention this, but even one instance
of something like this for Barack Obama would
have been a 24, seven scandal on corporate
and right wing media for weeks at least.
But it was almost completely ignored by the
Sunday morning talk shows and got relatively
little coverage over the weekend.
First of all, uh, we are talking here about
magazine advice columnist and former Miss
Indiana University.
He, Jean Carol, who has accused Donald Trump
of attacking her and raping her at a New York
department store in the late 1990s.
Um, the, uh, Carol says that she ran into
Trump in the fall of 95 or spring of [inaudible]
96 at the Bergdorf Goodman department store
in New York City where she says he attacked
her in one of the dressing rooms, uh, claims
that Donald Trump pressured her to try on
lingerie, grabbed her arm to pull her towards
the rest at dressing room.
And then I will read her quote and I warn
you, it is extremely graphic and disturbing
quote.
The moment the dressing room door is closed,
he lunges at me, pushes me against the wall,
hitting my head quite badly and puts his mouth
against my lips.
I am so shocked.
I shove him back and start laughing again.
He sees both my arms and pushes me up against
the wall a second time and as I become aware
of how large he is, he holds me against the
wall with his shoulder and jams his hand under
my coat dress and pulls down my tights.
I'm astonished by what I'm about to write.
I keep laughing the next moment still wearing
correct business attire, shirt, tie, suit,
jacket, overcoat.
He opens the overcoat unzips his pants and
forcing his fingers around my private area,
thrust his penis halfway or completely.
I'm not certain inside me.
This is an allegation of rape.
She's alleging that she was raped by Donald
Trump.
Now Trump has denied it, says he has no idea
who the woman is.
A picture has since been published of Donald
Trump with the accuser Eugene Carol and close
to total silence about this on the big five
Sunday talk shows, ABC, CBS, CNN, MSNBC, and
Fox all have the Sunday talk shows.
Mike Pence was interviewed.
Bernie Sanders was interviewed, uh, no mentions
of the new rape allegations against Donald
Trump.
So a couple of things to talk about here.
First of all, if the corporate media, we're
all as liberally biased as Donald Trump and
Republicans and Trump's sycophants claim corporate
media to be liberally biased, this would have
been a topic of discussion yesterday, period.
Number two, the hypocrisy of Republicans who
uniformly jumped behind any allegation no
matter who makes it against Democrats.
Like for example, against Bill Clinton, Juanita
Broaddrick in 1999 or whoever else, they now
are ignoring more than a dozen allegations
against Donald Trump.
If this is mere politics, why couldn't some
of the allegations against Bill Clinton had
been given the same benefit of the doubt as
they are providing to the allegations against
Donald Trump?
Uh, but in any other presidency, it's really
important to understand that this would be
front page news, nonstop period.
Now, I would also be curious to know, asking
all the people who hated Barack Obama and
thought he was the worst person in the world,
that he had committed all sorts of crimes,
that he was, in some cases a shape shifting
antichrist that he was planning to declare
martial law and suspend the 2016 election
to try to stay in power indefinitely.
Why is it that no one thought to concoct sexual
assault allegations against Barack Obama?
I mean, not only are there not sexual assault
allegations against Barack Obama, uh, there
are not even, uh, what we could call political
sexual assault allegations against Barack
Obama.
And for those who say, this is a tactic that
the left uses against Republicans, fake sexual
assault allegations, why were there no sexual
assault allegations against Republican President
George W. Bush?
So the point is, it's not based.
In fact to claim every president has sexual
assault accusers and they're widely understood
to be fake and attempts to take down presidents.
No.
Most presidents do not have sexual assault
allegations levied against them and Donald
Trump having 12 or 15 or eight, I don't even
know what the number is at this point, including
remember child rape allegations, which I have
covered, but have not received nearly enough
attention.
This is different.
Okay.
It is not even remotely reasonable to say
presidents, they always have all sorts of
sexual assault allegations against them.
Know Barack Obama didn't, uh, George W. Bush
didn't.
Now, as far as the corporate media coverage,
is this not getting coverage because even
the reporters and the media have become totally
numb too and desensitized to Donald Trump's
treatment of women.
Is it that they have calculated that there
is little upside to covering the 17th or the
19th or whatever allegation because the first
12 or 15 or 17 didn't get traction?
What do you think is going on here?
Is what's going on as shocking and disturbing
as that or is there something else that is
preventing this from getting coverage?